lots of people have of course been
wondering when were they going to
maybe announce that she was pregnant i
know that prince harry
obviously loves spending time with
children we've seen
him and megan on all those engagements
always going out there
talking to as many children as possible
and i think of course it was inevitable
when they got married everyone was
watching to find out when exactly we
might see
a little bump and when they might be
pregnant but yeah this evening we were
there at a briefing
the palace outlining the various
engagements that they've got coming up
over the next two and a half weeks and
after that it was then announced that
the duke and duchess
are expecting their first child in a
statement kensington palace have said
that they're all highnesses
at the duke and duchess of sussex are
very pleased to announce that the
duchess of sussex
is expecting a baby in spring 2019.
they also go on to say that their royal
highnesses appreciated all the
support that they've received from
people around the world since they got
married
in may and they are delighted to share
the news with the public of course
any couple wants to share the news with
their family and we're told that harry
and megan were able to tell
the rest of the royal family about their
happy news on friday
at princess eugenie's wedding we're told
that the queen the duke of edinburgh
prince charles the duchess of cornwall
and the duke and duchess of cambridge
are all
absolutely delighted at the news we're
also told that megan's mother
doria ragland is very excited that she
will soon
be welcoming her first grandchild into
the world but one thing that we did ask
about is whether or not
thomas markle so megan's father had been
told that his daughter
was pregnant and all we were told is
that there was
no comment of course the next two and a
half weeks are expected to be incredibly
busy
anyway they are visiting four different
countries they are
going to be carrying out 70 different
engagements
and the crowds i think it was always
inevitable there were going to be big
crowds coming out to see them
there's loads of coverage already here
in australia about their visit
but i think this news that they are
expecting their first baby next year is
only going to ramp up the excitement